uh i i hate to go back to our story of
projection but i sort of have to
one of the big stories that republicans
have been telling for a long time now is
uh democrats are going to commit fraud
when it comes to the election
democrats are going to send people out
to vote twice democrats are going to
send out
people to vote in the names of those who
have died
they're going to do all these different
things and of course none of it happened
but we now have yet another example
of a republican who did just that
and it's a trump staffer a former trump
staffer who was running for the new
hampshire house
voted in two states in 2016. we're going
to go through it but then it's also an
important opportunity to clarify
things that are actually against the law
versus things that are really no big
deal that republicans still say are
against the law associated press reports
trump aide seeking new hampshire house
seat
voted in two states in 2016. a former
trump administration official now
running for congress in new hampshire
voted twice during the 2016 primary
election season potent potentially
violating federal voting law
and of course leaving him at odds with
the republican party's focus on
so-called election integrity we're
talking about matt mowers or mowers
a leading republican primary candidate
who wants to upset
unseat rather democratic rep chris
pappas
matt mowers cast an absentee ballot in
new hampshire's 2016 presidential
primary according to voting records at
the time he was the director of former
new jersey governor chris christie's
presidential campaign four months later
chris christie was gone and mowers cast
another ballot in the new jersey
republican presidential primary using
his
parents address to re-register in his
home state
is this against the law it appears to be
legal experts say his actions could
violate a federal law that prohibits
more voting more than once in any
general
special or primary election that
includes casting a ballot in separate
jurisdictions so there are two or three
different stories here first of all when
republicans go on and on about voter
fraud
they want to make it seem like they're
accusing the other side they seem to
have been describing their own actions
it's almost like these republican
allegations end up being confessions oh
no you can't vote for hillary because
she won't be trustworthy with classified
information and she had a private email
server
we know how that turned out and uh it's
the exact same thing here but what i
really want to focus in on because
listen
they we keep catching these republicans
doing this stuff it's almost not even
news that they keep getting caught doing
this stuff mark meadows
uh uh voting registered in two states
all these different things
important reminder
just because the right says something is
illegal doesn't mean it is and let me
give you some examples
being registered
in two different states
is not against the law as long as you
don't vote in two different states what
malwares did appears to be illegal but
it is not uncommon that people live in
one state and are registered there
um and then after the primary and before
the general they move to a different
state and then they register there and
they legally vote as long as you didn't
vote in both states just being
registered in two places is not against
the law
and uh
we have to remember that secondly they
say well
dead people voted tons of dead people
voted there's no evidence of that but
what sometimes happens is somebody was
alive
you vote by mail absentee and then you
die before the date of the general
election
that's not against the law you haven't
done anything wrong you were alive when
you voted it becomes a clerical issue
another example people voted twice
oftentimes republicans will find that
someone was registered in two places and
they will say this person voted twice as
long as you didn't actually vote twice
you're not doing anything wrong it's a
clerical issue that the old place where
you lived hasn't deregistered you it's
important to remember the mass scale
stuff they claim is happening isn't
happening but a lot of the things that
happen anecdotally are not actually
against the law
do they actually care that people
understand that of course not of course
not uh make sure you are following us on
instagram at david pakman show we'll
take a quick break and be back after
this with much much more
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video